google releases imagine an unprecedented
text to image model hog view 2 improves
drastically over cog view 1 and mid
journey moves into open beta welcome to
ml news
[Music]
hello hello and welcome to ml news today
we talk all about text to image models
text and image models any sort of
artistic models that we might have
missed and developments over this summer
the first obviously really big one that
we've actually missed at the time is
imagine imagine is a system by google
specifically google research out of
toronto that is a diffusion model that
goes from text to images here you can
see a bunch of examples so this is an
alien octopus floating through a portal
reading a newspaper and this is not some
sort of image to image model the image
is created purely from the text which is
crazy so i hope you see that over the
last few years or even months this
quality of text image models has
improved drastically i think ever since
the first dali model kind of sparked
this push into this area the rate of
progress has been unprecedented look at
the quality of these things and also the
adherence to text is quite amazing now
not only is the quality really good
what's also really stunning is the
simplicity of these models we see a
continued progression from more
complicated systems to actually less
complicated systems so the entire
imagine system is just captured in this
diagram right here at the beginning you
have a text that goes into a frozen text
encoder so the text encoder isn't even
trained with the model it's simply used
as is from being trained as a pure text
model the text embedding is then fed
into a text to image diffusion model now
diffusion models have gained in
popularity in also the last few months
competing in quality with auto
aggressive models so this is a really
cool development whereas systems like
dolly 2 use the conglomeration of like
latent diffusion and so on this model
simply takes the text embedding feeds it
into this diffusion model generates a
low resolution 64 by 64 image and then
feeds that into super resolution
diffusion models in fact there are two
stages of super resolution the first one
going to 256 by 256 and then the second
one going to 1024 by 1024 obviously this
is a cool tactic because super
resolution models can be trained in a
very unsupervised way you simply take a
large image you sample it down to a
smaller image and you train the model to
go in the reverse direction now while
recent progression is definitely in the
direction of simplicity and scale you
can't just scale up and be simple and
expect that to work well there are
actually distinct things you can do to
make these models work a lot better and
the imagined paper points out a few of
those things for example we show that
large pre-trained frozen text encoders
are very effective and in fact we show
that scaling the pre-trained text
encoder size is more important than
scaling the diffusion model size which
is really interesting because you would
think that for an image generation model
the part that actually generates the
image is really important but it's
actually the part that pays attention to
the text and what's contained in the
text that seems to be more benefiting
from scale so the quality and adherence
to the prompt that we see in this model
is thanks in large part to scaling up
the text part of the model another thing
they also mention as being a core
contributor to the good quality is what
they call a dynamic thresholding
diffusion sampler which enables the use
of a very large classifier-free guidance
weights now there are a bunch of
technical terms if you haven't followed
this literature essentially in diffusion
models what you do is you have this
model that you feed the same image over
and over and in each step of that
feeding the image gets a little bit more
clearer a little bit more denoised so
you train the model to go from noise to
image in sort of a recursive step now in
each part of that recursion obviously
you generate a new image you generate
each pixel of the image in a given value
now if you know things about images you
know that usually pixel values go either
from 0 to 255 or negative 1 to 1 or you
know however you specified but there is
a minimum and maximum value for each
pixel and usually this is only important
at the end when you actually want to
have the output image you need to crop
it somehow to that range or squeeze it
or something like this during the
intermediate steps you have multiple
options you can simply let the system
run rampant and and have pixel values in
whatever like this pixel is 10
334.2 or at each step you can try to
limit it to some range and compress the
image now both of these options if you
do them in a static way don't really
seem appealing and that's what this
paper notices so they introduce a
technique to dynamically threshold to
dynamically reduce the range of pixels
during the recursive steps in the middle
of the diffusion process in the paper
they describe this in a bit more detail
they say that at each sampling step they
don't just threshold to like a fixed
value but they threshold to a percentile
of the absolute pixel values in the
image and then dynamically crop the
pictures to that value and then compress
that to a range of negative one to one
they say that we find that dynamic
thresholding results in significantly
better photo realism as well as better
image text alignment especially when
using very large guidance weights so
there's another thing if you haven't
followed this literature there is this
concept of classifier free guidance
which is a bit of a hack so the way it
works is that this model trains to go
from text to image so every procedure
every generation is conditioned on a
piece of text however you can do a trick
namely during training you sometimes
just leave away the text yet you still
try to generate the same image and that
teaches the model to just
unconditionally generate images without
the help of the text and then at
inference time here's the trick what you
do is you take the text you take the
text encoding and you run two
generations in parallel one of them you
actually feed the text encoding so
that's the real one the conditioned one
and one of them you don't feed the text
encoding but the same kind of input
noise otherwise and you let that process
run now at any intermediate step now you
have a clear diff between what happens
if i add the text and what happens if
from the same starting point i simply
generate the image without that text so
you have a diff like a vector between
the two images and what you can do now
is you can simply scale that up you can
simply say well more of that which
presumably leads you into a direction of
more conditioning on that text so people
find that this increases the amount by
which the model pays attention to the
text naturally however that comes with
its set of problems and one of them is
more saturated pixels more pixels out of
range and less photorealism because
these pixels usually get cropped the
dynamic thresholding helps with that so
i'm sorry that was a bit of a
long-winded explanation however they do
state that this is a core contributor to
the quality of their outputs if you want
to learn more the paper is called
photorealistic text-to-image diffusion
models with deep language understanding
the allen institute for ai releases
unified io which is a general purpose
model with what they claim unprecedented
breath that can perform a wide array of
visual and linguistic tasks so the
mission here is to cover all kinds of
tasks for example image generation
region captioning pose estimation
detection segmentation segmentation
based generation you get the idea
there's a lot of tasks that a single
model covers and what does it do it
simply defines encoders and decoders of
each of these modalities to a unified
token vocabulary so whether it's images
whether it's text whether it's anything
their goal is to translate this from and
to a unified set of tokens over which
they can run our very classic
token-based nlp auto-regressive models
we have a bunch of examples here so one
class of tasks they can handle is image
plus text to image now image plus text
you might think of descriptions to
photographs but you can do so much more
if you simply formulate it correctly
this is very much in the style of
something like t5 so for example if you
think of segmentation based generation
the input image isn't a photo but it's
the segmentation map and the input text
isn't the description but it's kind of
like a task description generate an
image for this segmentation and then an
annotation so this is part of the prompt
what the colors mean the model maps both
the image and the text to its latent
vocabulary and the output is an image in
this case the generated image now
another class of models is for example
image plus text to text so for example
the task of region captioning has an
image and inside the image there is a
bounding box bounding boxes can also
naturally be translated to like x and y
positions width and height into a set of
redefined tokens and a text describes
the tasks to be done what does the
highlighted region described the output
is a piece of text you get the idea the
model is sort of trained on all of these
tasks and all of these tasks are mapped
to a unified language a unified set of
tokens and that enables the model to
essentially cross learn all of these
different things and benefit from the
data of all the tasks that might or
might not be related so there is a blog
post and the paper isn't out yet but it
says it's coming late on 6 16 which is
about one and a half months ago so we're
all holding our breaths
hog view 2 is a new model from
researchers of tsinghua university that
is also a text to image model now cog
view 2 is a model that works in english
and chinese it is open there is a
hugging face demo available and it
focuses mainly on improving performance
over the previous system called cog view
1. so the paper that is called faster
and better text to image generation via
hierarchical transformers goes a lot
into detail on how they improve the
model since the last iteration and again
you can see that the quality and
adherence to text of these models is
really picking up in steam so the way
that cog view 2 improves in performance
and also in quality is by using a
sequence of transformations and instead
of having fully auto regressive models
they have partially bi-directional
models so in multiple stages they train
the model to only fill in local parts of
the image while attending to all the
other image tokens this allows them to
support some degree of bi-directionality
while also decoupling some of the
generations via local attention so
you're able to generate multiple parts
of the image at the same time for
example in their super resolution steps
as you can see here you can create a lot
of the things in parallel which gives a
great increase in inference speed there
is a demo on hogging face spaces if you
want to play around with it i'll link it
in the description
motherboard writes google bans deep
fakes from its machine learning platform
so apparently a lot of people have used
collabs to generate deep fakes and
google now disallows that use of collab
a lot of people have asked like how are
they gonna do that how are they gonna
inspect the code that you run or
something like this the way i understand
it is that as of now it's simply the
terms of use of collapse prohibit you
from running deep fake software so if
you run code like this you'd simply be
violating your contract with google how
and when and how strictly they're
actually going to check what code you
are running that i think is not
described currently i can imagine that
they are going to simply ban the
commonly shared collapse that people you
know kind of share around to generate
deep fakes a lot of the people who do
this kind of stuff they don't really
have an idea even of how collabs work or
what the code means they simply know how
to fill in the stuff and then click play
so that should weed out like a large
part of users of this technology now
while obviously google has the absolute
right to do this it gets a bit gray in
what counts as like deep fake software
there are obviously a lot of research
projects and even a lot of fun projects
that in one way of looking at them would
fall under the guise of of deep fake
software but are completely harmless and
there are other projects that might fall
under this category depending on how
loosely you define it and the question
is essentially how widely is this going
to be applied and as always i guess
we'll just have to wait for precedent
cases my hope is essentially that google
is going to take a quite strict approach
to this in that if you try some new
method to combine mickey mouse and
pikachu then that doesn't necessarily
count as a deep fake but we never know
it's always kind of scary when these
companies introduce rules that are
essentially up to their own mercy to
decide what falls under them and what
doesn't but i guess that's the entire
tech industry so yeah
cosmopolitan has an article about itself
namely about how it designed one of its
covers using dali so the cosmopolitan
issue is called the ai issue meet the
world's first artificially intelligent
magazine cover this is a bit
tongue-in-cheek obviously the cover
isn't really intelligent however it was
created by openai's dolly 2 system now
there is a video by the artist who made
the cover detailing the entire process
on brainstorming meeting with the team
then trying out different prompts
getting closer and closer to the final
result and i think this highlights a
core notion about these new text to
image models so as you can see here it's
not simply give me a cool cosmo cover it
is trying and trying modifying the
prompt trying again coming up with new
ideas brainstorming it's really kind of
like almost like a collaboration between
artists and these tools be that in
prompt engineering be that in then
modifying the image as you know dali can
not only generate images it can also
modify parts of existing images
according to some text stuff so the
prompt that they came up with is a wide
angle shot from below of a female
astronaut with an athletic feminine body
walking with swagger towards camera on
mars in an infinite universe synthwave
digital art it's only missing uh
trending on art station i guess or
unreal engine but yeah very cool insight
if you wanna watch the video it's karen
x chang on instagram and one thing that
i noticed about this is the fact here it
says and it only took 20 seconds to make
now from the video you just saw do you
have the feeling that this thing only
took 20 seconds to make like no that is
a bit misleading obviously the inference
time of dali is 20 seconds but then the
entire process of making the cover is
days weeks months so it's not
necessarily a replacement for the
traditional artist it's more like a
replacement for the photoshop person i
mean watch me do this okay right click
copy
[ __ ]
all right [ __ ] is open paste
cool colors saturation crank that up yo
bang and boom i have made a new magazine
cover if i told you that this magazine
cover in its entirety only took 10
seconds to make because it literally
took me 10 seconds to perform that
sequence of actions would you think
that's an accurate representation of how
this picture came to be probably not but
let's just forgive cosmopolitan for the
small amount of click bait here and
thank them for bringing the message of
how ai can support creativity into the
wider world
speaking of working with dali gee
parsons on twitter that is at guyp has a
big thread on what he calls tips tricks
games experiments and combinations for
dali and just kind of ideas of how you
can interact with dali now this is
targeted specifically towards dali but
obviously this is also gonna work for a
lot of these other text to image systems
as they all have very common bases very
common weaknesses and uh very common
ways of interacting with them now he has
more threads for example this one saying
dolly 2 generates amazing ai images but
using these 10 free tools can make them
so much better in which he goes into
post-processing essentially taking the
things you get from dali and in various
ways improving upon them animating them
making them better and so on and on top
of that he also released a free 82-page
book the dolly prompt book in which he
summarizes and elaborates on all of
these things in how you can interact
with these text-to-image models in a
efficient in a creative and in a more
productive way as i said the book is
available for free and if you are into a
career of dolly prompt engineer in the
future i definitely recommend you read
it
mid journey has just recently announced
that they're now moving to open beta
which essentially means that you can now
join without an invite now if you are on
twitter i'm sure you've seen mid-journey
generations they are super cool if not
just search for hashtag mid journey on
twitter and you're gonna find like a lot
of very amazing generations this one's
called the roots of infinity now mid
journey is open but it's not free there
is like a credit system however it is
pretty affordable to run a few prompts
and with the help of the previous
resources you should be able to come up
with quite creative prompts in order to
test out the system they also have an
elaborate page of instructions and faqs
in order to help you get going and
produce the best results possible
i've mentioned this one before but dali
mini is now called kryon notice the
spelling it's c-r-a-i-y-o-n
this after openai was quite displeased
with the naming conflict uh dali mini
being sort of very interchangeable with
dali so that gave the impression that
the two had to do something with one
another which obviously they do as dali
mini is an open source recreation of the
dolly system however dolly mini has now
been rebranded as crayon just to make it
clear that it is its own project now the
name dolly mini is actually in another
way not really descriptive as the system
is now powered by the dali mega model so
the faq says the model used is called
dali mini specifically the larger
version also known as dolly mega so if
you've used this and you've recently
noticed a bit of a bump in performance
that's because the model has been
upgraded and it's generally still fun to
play around with these things this is
sunrise outdoor weightlifting and also
here you can apply any of the techniques
we discussed before the model is also
open source so if you don't want to wait
for the servers or want to modify it or
run it on your own you can do so all
right and just two quick helpful
resources for this episode one is the
deep learning curriculum by jacob hilton
which is a curriculum like a set of
resources there where you can learn
about deep learning specifically about
stuff that jacob is interested in this
ranges from transformers scaling laws up
to optimization reinforcement learning
interpretability and more there's also a
set of links to other resources so this
in general is pretty helpful if you're
kind of into machine learning into deep
learning but some topics you might want
to expand your basic knowledge and the
other one is the pen and paper exercises
in machine learning by michael you
gottman which is on archive and is a pdf
that goes over various things as it says
it's pen and paper exercises so one
chapter for example is factor graphs and
message passing so you get a graphs you
get the factors and you get an exercise
mark the graph with arrows indicating
all messages that need to be computed
for the computation of p of x1 and then
there's a solution so the pdf covers a
lot of different areas as you can see
right here linear algebra optimization
direct graphical models undirected
graphical models hidden markov models
model based learning sampling and
variational inference very cool 200
pages of gruelsome exercises just for
you alright this was it for this week's
ml news i'm well aware that i've in no
way covered or exhausted the space of
text to image models or artistic models
there are a lot of things out there i
just wanted to give you a bit of an
overview what happened in recent weeks
let me know what you think in the
comments and as always stay hydrated and
i'll see you next time bye
[Music]
you